y'a un truc qui est sorti il a
dernièrement tailles tous un gros coup
de gueule tout à l'heure en début
d'après midi
c'est contre la presse et plus
particulièrement contre un article de
paris match marque même si l'artiste est
bien intentionnés je suis horrifié de
lire les propos qu'ont près dans cet
entretien
ce ne sont pas les miens je crois avoir
le souci de la franchise certes mais
aussi de la nuance et du respect lorsque
je m'exprime alors c'est un truc qui est
sorti dans paris match
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait c'est
quoi l'histoire en vrai en vrai c'est
pas si évidemment ce n'est pas si
important que ça va pas bien sûr en vrai
je mets ça juste parce que parce que
dedans je mourrai pas que des gens qui
me suivent et tout lisse quelque chose
qui correspond pas à la personne qui
pense qu nettement là c'est compliqué
mon truc non mais t'inquiète on a
compris d'ailleurs d'ailleurs dans la
chanson les imbéciles il dit à un moment
je les ai noté écrit dans les magazines
d'être débile oui j'aime beaucoup être
débile
ouais non mais ce qui compte c'est que
ça vous plaît pas moi je veux pas
enfoncé j'ai dit j'ai parlé en direct
avec le gac à 1 qu'un bon gars et
pensait bien faire et parfois pour bien
faire des journalistes ils sont juste
caricature un peu de faire un cv à la
phrase qui vous a dérangé
oui on avait pas mal mais c'est que
juste parfois j'étais entre guillemets
je vois des trucs cependant qu'il ait
dit émergent où ils vont retrouver pas
exactement ce que vous en faites c'est
tellement rare je lui dis la vérité ça
m'arrive jamais ça m'arrivait trois fois
en jeu pendant des centaines
d'interviews mon père n'a voulu rajouter
quelque chose là-dessus mais je viens de
le dire
alors c'est quoi je les vis et dans sa
chambre les imbéciles ils en parlent ils
écrit dans le magazine d'encre débile
j'ai bien aimé l'expression allez y je
peux je vais t'expliquer j'ai quand même
prendre le dessus et faire un petit
match de foot une émission car 11 en
l'air je veux bien te la [ __ ]
18h21 antoine lacarrière dames et
bonjean de carrière mais ça tu es
je vais dire ce qui va se passer entre
toi et moi ici tu vois là voilà la
l'ensemble de l'établissement où ça va
coûter bonbon encore un gars comme toi
qui revient d'une séance d'uv fait une
idole à une intervention comme ça ça
c'est 350 mille téléspectateurs alors
sur evans m
j'ai eu le temps alors le fait pas c'est
le groupe lagardère ils ont peut-être
beaucoup d'un meilleur ce qu'on n'a pas
notre heureusement hanouna c'est pas la
garder là bas tu fais ce que tu veux ici
à luna toit et ses bas elle se bat tous
les jours en fin donc je me sens bien à
toi d'accord mais coûte quand même celle
que tu te dis donc je t'aime beaucoup
mais non stop ce sens ce qui me fout pas
tout l'air j'ai bourlingué l'apport en
arriver là
j'ai bossé toute la journée tous à la d6
les invités que je connais même pas
qu'ils viennent dégâts tout ça et joel
madden
c'est à dire papa de la fille du sud
alors c'est très bien mais voilà il
recommence je les lis j'ai purgé un
match aussi
écoutez moi bien ça va très mal à
l'épaule très mal allez pour vous